hello everybody welcome to ask doc live
my name is rebecca kozak and i am
excited to have you here with us on ask
doc live now this is a program that we
are bringing to you as a resource
where you are able to
come and ask questions in regards to
what you can do to be empowered
and take control over your own health so
i want to make sure that everybody is in
the right place
i know i am so thankful that i was able
to take control of my health and be
empowered and not
rely on a system that was failing so
found a system that is working and i
just want to make sure that i am able to
share it with the world
so hello world
welcome to ask doc live again my name is
rebecca dukes kozak and i will be your
host for the next two hours where we
will be bringing information that you
probably won't hear anywhere else you
might hear little bits and pieces but
you're not going to see the big story
or hear the big story on other programs
and the big story for us is coming
through years and years of research that
has been funded by
the nih
and for those of you who don't know
about the nih
congratulations on not watching tv
recently
so
um
but if you are on live with us
today we do have the chat menu on
and we want to make sure that if you
have a question though raise your hand
in the zoom menu
you will see the option or something
that says reactions
reactions will give you the option to
raise your hand so we want to make sure
that
if you have a question you know how to
raise your hand because i will going be
going through
the hands as they are raised in that
order and then for those of you who have
emailed into us
i'll be going through and touching
through emails there as well
now the content of this program is to
provide educational information only on
the importance of
nutritional
supplementation
our food supplies folks they are void of
the nutrition that our body needs not
just to survive but actually thrive and
in this program we will be sharing
nutritional options that are available
through
programs that we have found that
actually work
and it's not just based on one person
two person we're talking millions of
people that have filled the gaps in
their nutrition
and are now
realizing the positive results and
looking forward to old age i know i was
not
even six years ago looking forward to
getting older and now at 50 i feel
better than i did in my early 20s
now the fda does require us to let you
know that this is not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
and this program is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
but we are joined by the good doctor dr
joel wallach who has been instrumental
in suing the fda
nine times with victories
and these victories have led to the
addition of vital nutrients added to
foods and allowing the distribution of
information like the program that you
are
following today
proven by science to be factual and the
essential need of supplementation
against disease
so we also bring to you
good news that the genetic theory has
been proven incorrect
now this science proving genetic theory
incorrect is called epigenetics
and epigenetics is the study how your
behaviors and environment can cause
changes that affect the way your genes
work
in with epigenetics you're in control
it's not taking control away from you
where
having a genetic tag
kind of
has left people feeling hopeless well
guess what let's throw that tag away
let's look at epigenetics and let's
create healthier health journeys for
everyone we know and love
and to guide us on this
journey we have the one
and only the amazing the doctor that
gave me my life back after i fired mine
who had given up on me and pushed me off
to
pain management
i'm so glad that i found dr joel wallock
dr wallach thank you so much for joining
us
well thank you for all the kind words in
the history there appreciate that
rebecca super job as usual and you look
like you're you look like you're 30.
well i don't know what 30 is supposed to
feel like but i know i feel better now
at 50 than i did in my early 20s
wow
what a great testimony
okay
well i know you have a couple of
questions you want to ask me so let's
start out with those things and then we
can get into my story of the day
okay so dr wellick um i have a lady that
i'm working with who has c-reactive
protein
and her doctor is telling her to stop
eating meat now meat has some amazing
properties to it i mean it supports our
own muscle
within our body so cutting that out it
doesn't sound like it makes
any sense to me
what would your recommendations be
well first of all she needs to get
another doctor okay
find another doctor get another opinion
okay
and um c-reactive proteins are produced
by the liver liver makes them and they
float around through the bloodstream
and what they do is they identify
parasites bacteria viruses and dead and
dying and wounded cells from all tissues
and they kind of attach to those dead
and wounded cells
and
once the c-reactive protein attaches to
the wounded and dead
cells
your white blood cells
looks at that beacon coming up and goes
and eats the dead cells
okay so it's kind of a system there and
the early warning part of the system is
the c-reactive protein so that's what as
far as made by the liver it's a natural
process
and so when somebody has high levels of
c-reactive proteins that means there's
lots of inflammation
lots of nutritional deficiencies so
cells are dying early they're not well
and they're sending out help signals and
so forth and so the c-reactive proteins
are generated in larger quantities by
the liver to cope with all this and so
the doctor is
misinterpreting what's going on here
okay
and so instead of changing the diet and
taking supplements which has solved the
problem
he wants to put her in some kind of
institution and get some um
therapy that just deals with symptoms
symptomatic relief until she dies and so
yeah she needs to find a different
doctor because this guy
really doesn't know what's going on here
okay
yeah that's great information dr wallach
i mean it's it's one of those what you
call red warning lights yes exactly
it's a red warning light exactly
you hit the nail right on the head
so we we need to pay attention to those
red warning lights those symptoms of
things that we've got going on
and
not like i said before not
accept that label
searching
and of course you appreciate that the
good lord
just think of all the things that the
good lord did when he created
animals and humans and plants and things
all these various systems
he put in there
okay and so this is not something that
just accidentally happened this is too
uh which i say it's too scientific and
it's too
um
critical and it's too organized for just
happened accidentally so the good lord
put that system in there to give us
uh contribute to
adding 25 to 50 healthful years to our
life and you know for your own personal
experience
okay how
good you look how good you feel and you
have to have lots of compliments from
people who've known you for years and
years and years well can tell me so sit
down here tell me what you're doing
rebecca because you're looking younger
every year and i'm looking older every
year what are you doing
i i have people that i graduated with
that are
are reaching out and
you know many of them are sick many of
them have
i mean there's just this last year dr
wallach i've had four classmates die of
cancer
oh my gosh yeah well that's diet and
lack of supplementation
bad diet and lack of cementation cancer
is caused by a bad diet and lack of
supplementation and so if you do a good
diet and supplement you can reduce your
risk of cancer at almost zero
well
i'm on it
okay i'm on it
so what would you like to share with us
today dr
wellick okay well you hear me all the
time rebecca's saying we should eat like
asians you know instead of instead of
eating like europeans no wheat brother
and oats no gluten
and the asians you know the when you
look at who lives the longest the
japanese
have the longest um
uh life
expectancy at 84.7 just about 85 years
that's 10 years longer than us we're
supposed to have the best health care
system in the world no that's not true
we got the most expensive but it's not
the best
and then yeah and then you look at the
hunzas between pakistan and china
uh they're they're life expectancy i'm
saying that the japanese have the
longest life expectancy for the
industrialized nations
for the not industrialized nations the
hunzas between pakistan and china their
life expectancy is a hundred
and there is a book and a movie
generated about them because their
longevity
and
the book and the movie were entitled
lost horizon you go to amazon and get
the book and the book was written i
think like 1916 and the movie came out
in
1926 or 27 something like that and so
you'd have to go to amazon to get the
book and the cd
now or the movie however they'll have it
available
and then i need to jump back to japanese
they have the right now according to the
world health organization they have the
longest lived person in the
industrialized world kane tanaka which
we knew about some years ago but i
thought she was a he back then was a
cane to knock because actually is she
119 years of age and then next month
she'll be 120.
and she's walking around taking her
great great great great grandkids you
know into the parks and walking around
the block and cooking and doing all
kinds of great stuff at 119 years old
she's not in a nursing home
okay she's not in a senior care center
or anything like that
and she's still very functional
all right now
um so i i looked at the 50 united states
i asked siri and everybody can have siri
so i'm not going to go through the whole
list but um you can ask siri what what
is the life expectancy of each state of
the 50 states the united states okay and
it lists them
okay by the longest lives and the
shortest lived
okay and then a couple of those
um studies will show
the comparison
of the black community the latino
community and the white community in the
asian community in each of those states
and every state where they have a
significant asian community
the asians
excuse me always outlive the blacks the
whites and the latinos
by anywhere from five
to fifteen years
okay so
the the
the uh life expectancy of the
um asians and we're talking about
chinese japanese
koreans vietnamese
and so forth um
in these states
um they live to be
the oldest ones are living to be 90
years of age that's their life
expectancy is 90.
okay
and that's because of their diet
they don't eat gluten now there are
asians that eat gluten in northern china
they grow wheat they eat gluten
okay
um
and so in japan around the u.s military
bases they eat wheat
okay and so they pay a price for
diverting from their historical
background where they eat rice and sweet
potatoes and beans and squash and then
of course the philippines are the same
thing
and there's another piece to it here now
here came the piece that really shocked
me
how many active volcanoes do you think
that we have in the united states
i really don't know
okay well when you look at the usa
okay
uh let's see here usa
we have 169 active volcanoes
they're all along the west coast and
pacific between hawaii which you'd
expect some there right and alaska a lot
of active volcanoes in alaska i think
that's why putin wants us to give alaska
back to him
beside the gold and silver that's there
in oil
and
then of course washington state
um
dropped down to california and texas and
so forth and then you compare the
average life expectancy in the western
states where all these volcanoes are
compared to the east coast
okay the western states they live
from a life expectancy five to seven
years longer than the ones on the east
coast
it's all these minerals in the volcanic
ash
okay and the lava getting into our food
supply
okay through the tributaries and rivers
and uh through the air and so forth and
the dust and and ash falling on our our
crops and and so forth
and so this is very very important stuff
okay and just uh you know just a couple
of them um let's see here
hawaii the average life expectancy is 82
alaska's 79 washington state's 80.1
california is 80.8 texas 78.5 and when
you look at the east coast
west virginia well they're not quite the
east coast but almost the east coast
sort of east coast
midwest sort of thing west virginia
uh
74.4 years is 74.4 years less than
82 of course
okay it's eight years less they live
eight years less than the people on the
west coast because they don't get the
nutrition and their food that they get
on the west coast does 169
active volcanoes
and japan has 110 active volcanoes
that's why they lived 84.7
okay
india the third
let's see here the second largest
population in the world
1.3 billion people they have one active
volcano it's offshore so i don't get any
benefit from it we look at their states
and compare their life expectancy they
range from 62 to 70.
that's a significant difference oh yeah
and it all comes down to
volcanic ash
and lava sources of minerals okay
and i've got this all you know even um
israel they have two active volcanoes in
the golan heights and their average life
expectancy is 85. they live 10 years
longer than we americans live
in israel
okay surely god's favoring them
okay and so
um
you know this is unimpeachable stuff i
just get excited when there's that much
evidence and you look in the right
places it's there the answer is there
okay now with all that said i want to
say a few more things that are sort of
um parallel to that okay
um
of course everybody needs the 90
essential nutrients in this day these
days of the pandemic i prefer the 215
nutrients the healthy maintenance heart
pack the core of which is the 90.
and
you can add 25 to 50 healthy years your
life by staying away from the bad foods
the fried foods the processed meats the
oils the glutens the wheat brown rice
notes the sugar the carbonated drinks
you know the diet one's got to go
and take your 215 nutrients in the form
of the ultimate uh excuse me in the form
of the health of any heart pack kids
don't forget the kids um
young women and men who are in the child
bearing years they need to be taking the
90 90s essential nutrients for at least
six months to a year before they get
pregnant
and then we won't have kids with birth
defects okay all birth defects are
caused by nutritional deficiencies prior
to conception
and of course we have the kids tidy
whether the mother is breastfeeding the
babies or not they should still have a a
meal once a day when they're born the
mother's breastfeeding they should still
have one meal a day which is infamil
similac and put the kid's toddy in there
with the cherry mints and some efas
all right we have we have the efa pluses
back now you can order them
okay we had gosh so many back orders as
and so we had to get millions
okay of the efa pluses to fill the back
orders and still have stuff left over so
you need to really jump on those efa
pluses to go along with the efas
and then
the diseases that we doctors see the
most patients from this is published
every year
diabetes obesity high blood pressure
heart disease
kidney failure dialysis
and these are all nutritional
deficiencies not emerge genetic and none
of them are
caused by um autoimmune disease where
your body's attacking ourselves these
are all nutritional deficiency diseases
and so we have secret sauces you know we
have the healthy blood sugar pack for
people with diabetes don't go off your
diabetes medication you get on the
healthy blood sugar pack get off all the
bad foods and then as your blood sugar
begins to drop you can slowly reduce the
medication
dosage based on the numbers and usually
within six to ten weeks six to nine
weeks you won't be a diabetic anymore
okay we've been a diabetic for 20 years
same way with dialysis i don't care if
you haven't urinated in 10 years your
analysis is six days a week
uh usually within two weeks you'll be
down to dialysis three days a week and
then two more weeks you'll be off the
dialysis after
25 years on dialysis because you didn't
want to get a kidney transplant okay
and of course
dialysis what we'd like to do is the
healthy brain and heart pack plus the
ultimate daily classic tablets so they
can take
three of those twice a day per hundred
pounds of body weight and they're going
to support healthy blood flow through
the blocked arteries in the kidneys and
support healthy blood pressure as well
and it works every time it never fails
it never fails same way with the healthy
blood sugar pack it never fails
and then the heart issues
the healthy brain and heart pack is
self-explanatory
and then of course again the ultimate
daily classic tablet so it can get more
blood flowing through the coronary
arteries and the ar and so forth
and um
we actually have when people get white
grain silver hair it has nothing to do
with aging it's a red warning light in
this case a white silver or gray warning
light okay
because that same deficiency that's
causing you to lose hair color causes
aneurysms in your brain and aneurysms in
your aorta and your coronary arteries of
your heart it'll also cause a breakdown
of the valves which are made from
connective tissue like tendons in your
legs
so you need these nutrients to preserve
the integrity of the heart
the valves the muscle
the pericardium the sheath the covering
of the heart
all that kind of stuff your heart works
24 hours a day for the rest of your life
the heart works 24 hours a day
even when you're sleeping you got to
take care of that puppy okay and it's
one of those things where um
you have the control to do that
and then
uh we have osteoporosis osteoporosis of
course but the doctors will say you know
uh soon we're gonna have to do a double
knee replacement because you know
we did an x-ray you have osteoporosis in
both knees when you have osteoporosis in
one joint in your body you got in every
joint in your body okay
um it's not a localized thing
osteoporosis is a global thing in your
body
when you get osteoporosis of the skull
you get tinnitus ringing in the ears the
skull squeezes the
auditory branch of the age cranial nerve
which is easily repairable you get a
gradual loss of vision and the pressure
your eye goes up you get glaucoma
because the skull is squeezing the optic
artery the optic vein and the optic
nerve causing obstruction
of flow in both directions and so forth
and you're gradually losing your vision
the doctors want to do surgery and oh
you got cataracts you got glaucoma we're
gonna give you this truck we're gonna do
this search we're gonna put a little
pump in there and all this kind of stuff
and really all you gotta do is get rid
of all the bad foods
and and take all these nutrients in the
healthy brain and heart pack take extra
of our collagen peptides and scoop of
that with your drink in the morning a
scoop of that when you're drinking the
evening don't forget the msm three of
those with each meal you'll regrow every
bone in your body
in less than 90 days
i don't care if you've had osteoporosis
for 25 30 40 50 60 70 years and and
very quickly you regrow all that the
bone
and all of the associated tissues like
cartilage and ligaments and tendons and
so forth including the skull of course
we have one of my favorite books is
called it's all in your head there's 25
different diseases you get from
osteoporosis the skull
doctors love obviously approach to the
skull because it allows them to put
their kids through college because they
have so many diseases they can work on
you and they just give you symptomatic
relief
they don't solve the problem because it
doesn't
it doesn't
which they say compute with them
because they don't get training that you
get osteoporosis of the skull
there's a disease called paget's disease
where the skull goes from a quarter of
an inch normal to an inch sick when you
have patches disease and doctors want
you to believe that's an autoimmune
disease no it's osteoporosis when you
get osteoporosis the bones get bigger
because the connective tissue you're
trying to make up for the
lack of strength or the loss of strength
okay so with all that said i'm going to
send this back to you
rebecca and you can ask me anything you
want well doctor with all that said i
would like to kind of
circle back on birth defects
i'm sorry if you circle back on what
birth defects
oh birth defects okay that's one of my
favorite subjects but let's let's
include things like
autism dyslexia
um
adhd
herbs palsy
aedd
well and herbs palsy i mean those that's
not something that's
as well known as these other behavioral
conditions yes
yes okay these behavioral conditions are
caused by a lack of nutrition your brain
requires enormous amount of nutrition
okay it has all these functions
every every emotional thing you have is
a combination of your brain and hormones
okay
and so i want you to think about this
you have all this stuff going on now
um all these issues going on in the
schools about the transgender stuff is
like crazy uh going it is skyrocketing
in the schools
well that's because
um most um and i put my finger right in
the eye of ob gyns because when they see
these little girls they come in they're
having cycle problems you know they give
them hormone injections and hormone
pills and everything and they get relief
but they don't say take 90 essential
nutrients
so some years later when they get
pregnant whether by choice or by
accidents okay they get pregnant
they don't have enough nutrition
to develop the baby perfectly and the
hypothalamus which controls who you
chase for sex and who you allow to chase
you for sex and the pituitary who tells
you who to chase for sex and who to
allow to chase you for sex the pituitary
and the hypothalamus as the center sort
of internal part of the brain
when it's underdeveloped it didn't get
all the nutrition it needed to develop
200 maybe it's just banging along at 60
or 30 whatever it is
and that's why we have the hgh product
hdh product okay
it says supports all the functions of
the hypothalamus and the pituitary
okay i take three of those
twice a day okay and you know i'm 83
years old
i'm still going through puberty okay
it's one of those things where i'm
taking my hgh i take three of those
twice a day
and um i've been doing that since we
came out with that product which was i
don't know 15 years ago
and
it makes a huge difference and so these
kids
and remember they were going to
institutionalize me when i was nine
because i was hurting other people i had
what they would call today a very
aggressive type of tourette's syndrome i
would hurt people and i was very strong
throwing bills of hay
nine years of age i could beat up a 200
pound guy
um i was nine i only weighed you know
like 80 pounds or something like that
and um so
i began to eat vitamins and minerals in
the alfalfa pellets of animals and in
three days time i was cured and 20
different doctors that they took me to
over a five year period of time 20
different doctors couldn't figure it out
they never asked the right questions all
they did was ask about my behaviors and
then they would give me
tranquilizers and stuff like that as
opposed to trying to fix it
okay
and so this is not difficult
and again it's in the book it's all in
your head
it's in the book let's play doctor it's
in the book epigenetics it's in the book
um
uh hell's kitchen
and um
all of these things are caused
by lack of nutrition
and
electricity electricity has been the big
boogie man here why because when they
pulled the switch we went from wood
stoves and fireplaces with all those
wood ashes which you put into the garden
because wood ashes are 98 minerals and
don't two or three percent carbon
okay same way with fireplace sashes okay
that's what we used to put in our food
for spices that's what we used to put in
our gardens for fertilizer but when
electricity came along
bingo
all gone
and that's when all of our problems
began
okay
and of course there's certain places in
the world where they had problems
because of nutritional minerals did not
occur in a uniform blanket around the
crust of the earth they occur in veins
like gold and silver so just eating well
taking the four food groups and the
seven food group pyramid is not going to
consistently give you a good result so
would you put dirt from texas into the
tank of your car instead of gasoline no
would you put dirt from texas in your
oil pan instead of oil for your car no
well come on that's dirt from texas
there's bound to be some oil in it isn't
that okay
that's not not good enough well that's
the same stupid thinking that they say
when eat the four food groups or some
food group pyramid everything will be
fine every doctor who says that should
be put in jail
okay and they'll get the picture when
they start putting them in jail for
saying those kind of things is not true
well and i i want to correct make a
correction on my statement dyslexia is
not necessarily a behavioral
issue but
that's something that
you know because of my lack of nutrition
or absorption dr wallach that i have
within
three of my four boys
so what can we do and i mean they're
raging ranging from
10 to 33 now
what can i give them is going to help
them
with that connection between the eyes
and the brain and seeing
the words correctly
okay
so they need to
they could have osteoporosis as go
and um they need to
put us on
a thing here
where
um they're getting all 90 centuries they
need three eggs twice a day three eggs
twice a day
and um
tom chanel is trying to get a hold of me
i don't know what's the matter with him
he knows you and i run on the air i'll
mess with jim and tell him to leave you
alone keep going doctor okay
yeah
okay and so um then uh he you need to
get him on three eggs twice a day they
cannot be fried or hard boiled they
gotta be soft yolks okay to get the
cholesterol because cholesterol
is what the hormones are made from okay
they need the hgh they could take three
of those or five twice a day depending
on severity of their problems
they need to take the healthy brain and
heart pack they need the collagen
peptides they need the msm
and then they need the zero test they
could take three of those i do that i'd
take three twice a day
i'm 82 years old and i you know i don't
have any problems because i take my
three zero test twice a day and i ate my
eggs i had three eggs this morning along
with my wild rice i had three poached
eggs i had wild rice some mornings i'll
have sweet potatoes with butter
i also had this morning
instead of chicken or something like
that this morning or lamb chops i had
the chicken of the sea i had tuna okay
and boy that was good i had tuna fillets
oh my gosh
and so i want to point something out dr
wallach we have been programmed to think
that breakfast consists of pancakes
waffles french toast olive oil oatmeal
gluten alert gluten alert gluten alert
gluten alert boxed cereals
all of these things breakfast of
champions
yeah
sweeties
we need to get out of that box
you need to buy you need to get them all
together and give them to a doctor
better yet any doctor who's in jail
they should be forced to eat breakfast
cereals every morning for breakfast
so we'll just
you know donate food for for the job the
doctors that are already
in jail incarcerated that's correct
okay
so if tom wants to talk to us he needs
to get to you or
yeah he's missing
his program he needs to come to mind
right yeah
and so i don't know why he's he's
bugging us
but go ahead dr well like so as i know
we have hands up we have lots of
questions that are let's go for it
comments
so the let's go ahead and go to the
first
hand that is up and it is iphone 13
iphone 13 if you're able to turn your
camera on and join join us that would be
fabulous i just sent you a request on
you you are on live with dr wallach
hi
hi i'm celia
so i'm the one with the crp issue um
i also was diagnosed in uh well i'm 48
years old five to 150 pounds i also was
diagnosed with sarcoidosis in 2000 but i
actually had the symptoms when i was
like 16 years old
um
i didn't i just stopped i didn't catch
the first thing you said you had
something you gave me initials i didn't
oh so i'm the one with the um
the crp encryption crp
reactive protein
the one she asked you about um earlier
okay c c reactive protein yes the active
protein i'm sorry okay
um and my doctor told me to stop eating
meat so i haven't eaten meat for um it's
going on two years
um
also i was diagnosed with the
sarcoidosis um like in about a thousand
and i'm like in my 20s at that time but
i okay
okay because you said it twice now so i
get it all right um do you have any
diabetes or having pressure
no
okay all right so here we go now the bad
foods this will be for life this is
forever not for a couple of weeks until
you feel better okay this is forever no
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat bread
right now so
um
let's see here uh no um
uh
no
soft drinks okay you know none of the
none of the colas and 7-ups and stuff
like that even the diet one's got to go
and okay
if you want something for energy we have
our coffee we have it we have our um we
have a rebound okay
with a hundred nutrients in it don't
take it after four o'clock because it'll
keep you up all night and then at 150
pounds i want you to take two healthy
brain and heart packs for a month to
fulfill something twice a day i want you
to take
um two bottles a month for msms you can
take three with breakfast through the
lunch street dinner time that will
support and promote maintain a pair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
makes your bone itself
and then you need also the collagen
peptides get the big canisters you take
a scoop of that with your breakfast
drink and a scoop of that with your
dinner drink remember the reason why you
have high levels of c-reactive protein
is not because you're eating meat
because you have a lot of dead and dying
cells
okay the reason why you have dead dying
cell cells you're not getting enough
nutrition you're eating badly so you're
not absorbing anything
of nutrition and then you're not
supplementing properly well now you've
got to change all that you've got to
supplement properly got to get rid of
the bad food so you can absorb and then
um everything will come right
and um
then you you know when you get to where
you're really
very very good uh you want to send your
doctor an email
and just say okay i figured out how to
solve my problem thank you so much for
your advice uh in the in the past
um
uh i do have some books and cds i'd like
you to read
okay but um
you're gonna have to pay for them you're
a doctor you can afford to pay for them
i'm not gonna pay for them for you
you're going to pay for them yourself
and you go to www.drjwalik.com
and say i can help you with your
patience
um do you work outside the home you know
do what do you do outside the home
well i'm a nurse
okay so you're in the health industry
you say you know i'm a nurse i'm in the
health industry so you know i'm trying
to give you some good advice here to
help your patients so uh let's work
together here and see what we can do to
help some other people that have similar
problems that i had past tense okay okay
okay
so thank you so much especially because
all right because you are in the
healthcare industry
okay and i i hear you always saying
about the ringing in the ears the heart
tonight
yes everything that you name i have
every single you have osteoporosis go
you need to get a hold of that book it's
all in your head it has a formula in
there to deal with it
okay
okay you need that book it's all in your
head if you don't have it you need it
okay and uh i think you can get it
through
um
[Applause]
thank you john t
what
stock live
stock
welcome to the family your family now
yes okay you have a big responsibility
bigger than you had when you were a
nurse
right
yeah okay because as a nurse you're
dealing with an individual with their
individual problems now you're dealing
with community
okay okay you have this knowledge now
okay thank you god bless you dear look
forward to working with you
thank you
awesome thank you cecilia i work look
forward to working with you as well you
have amazing brother-in-law i have to
say i know thank you he's been helping
me out i've started all the vitamins
already so
fabulous keep going thank you
all right dr wellick the next we have a
question in regards to
okay so let me just read this she's 80
years old
she weighs
165 pounds
5 foot 4 inches
and she's been on a protocol for
osteoarthritis of the skull or
osteoporosis of the skull
and she has peeling skin
so it's very dry leathery feeling
um affects her face
okay
does she have white grass over here did
she send you a picture or anything so
you can see her hair i do not have a
picture but says that her skin and hair
have always been very oily
um until she had coveted and now
everything seems to have dried out
mm-hmm
okay that's probably because she's
changed her diet she's eating oatmeal
for breakfast every morning or something
like that something silly okay
so she has spurred you many times so i
think she's been making some changes
okay good well 165 pounds
80 years old she has obviously
approached the skull with tinnitus rain
in the years she got a regular heartbeat
is called atrial fibrillation
and the doctor's treatment for a
afib which is obviously approached to
the skull squeezing the 10th cranial
nerve the vagus nerve causing this afib
the doctor's approach to treating afib
is to anesthetize you cut your chest
open take your heart out and touch the
heart over various parts of the heart
with a hot branding iron hoping to find
the places making the heart beat
irregularly
it's a very dangerous uh procedure it
kills a lot of people do not get
ablation okay ablation look up the word
ablation it means kill
okay
okay so you do not want to get that
treatment
um but you do want to take the healthy
brain and heart pack 165 pounds you need
two of those
a month that's so you can take a full
dose twice a day you need to msm two
bottles a month you can take three
breakfasts through lunch with dinner you
need to get one of the large canisters
of collagen peptides you can take a
scoop of breakfast drink a scoop of
dinner drink don't forget about your age
vitamin d3 and three of those twice a
day that's two bottles a month
and this is not only going to help
um the skull and the brain but it's also
going to help the skin
okay we do also have hair skin and nails
she could take three of those twice
it'll be two vowels a month and then
call us every couple of weeks and she
needs to take some pictures of herself
now with her hair
because as the hair begins to change
color she's gonna look 25 30 years
younger she'll look like she's 50 years
old and people say did you get a hair
transplant are you coloring your hair
what are you doing you look 30 years
younger
no i'm taking these supplements and my
gray hair was due to a nutritional
deficiency it was kind of like a gray
warning light instead of a red warning
that's a great warning light okay and so
that's why
i'm looking younger because i've been
taking these supplements these nutrients
are not in our food anymore and that's
why i was having all these problems and
doctors wanted to solve my problems with
a double knee replacement
okay that kind of stuff and usually they
will have dental issues they'll have
receding gums they'll have bleeding gums
um they will you know oftentimes this
starts early so when they're a teenager
they'll go to an orthodontist because
their teeth are floating around and
falling out
kind of thing
because your jaw and your face is part
of the
uh of your skull so when you get
obviously close to the skull it's not
just the crown of your head but it's
also your face and your in your jaw
okay so that's all reversible it's all
reversible awesome thank you so much dr
wallach
let's go to the next hand that is up and
area code 774
go ahead and unmute yourself
if you're able to
area code 774
this will be the first time i've had a
caller be able to pull through so
let's see if it works there we go
can you hear us
i saw that they came unmuted
but i do not hear them do you hear
anybody dr wallach
no
all right okay i'm here now there you
are go ahead okay
okay i'm 60 years old
six feet tall
205 pounds
and i i just had bow surgery on my nose
for basal cell cancer
and uh then i had uh i think it's called
a flap which is a uh
the skin flap for my forehead to uh fix
the the uh the side of my nose
and now i'm looking at radiation therapy
so i'm wondering what uh
would be the best supplements to take
before radiation therapy
or to follow you know with the follow-up
of radiation therapy
just to pretend
okay do you have any other issues you
have any irritable bowel syndrome you
have any
heart disease you have anything like
high blood pressure diabetes
no i don't i don't all my labs are good
my teeth aren't great and my hair is
white but um you know generally my labs
are really good i exercise a lot okay
well
exercise without supplementation of
suicide i actually have a cd you need to
listen to exercise supplementation
suicide that's why athletes
the
professional athletes
die
at um let's see here's 71 except for
except for um
football players who die at 62
on the average okay
uh there's actually i have a cd out that
says exercise while supplementation
suicide
and so telling me exercise if you have
no history of supplementation tells me
why you have all your problems
okay the same thing that causes white
hair in a person causes heart death in
young athletes same deficiency because
of heart death and young athletes five
hundred thousand die in america each
year from sudden heart death
okay you hear about all the time
hypertrophy cardiomyopathy heart disease
some of the people who die when they get
the vaccination for covid will die from
cardiomyopathy heart disease they
already have that deficiency the heart
is just sort of
balancing on a hair and then they get
this
this um
inflammatory thing which is a a
vaccination it's inflammatory and and
the heart dies
okay
and so
um if they were taking the supplements
the heart wouldn't die but they're not
taking the supplements so when they get
to when they get the vaccination the
heart dies because they're missing that
nutrient that's required for the health
of the heart
okay okay so yep here here we go
um none of the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat broth rhinos no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go in this will be for the rest
of your life
and then at 205 pounds i want you to
take two healthy brain and heart packs
per month to fold over everything twice
a day obviously you get two bottles a
month for msms you can take three
breakfasts three at lunch street at a
time and they will support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
a vertebrae bone makes bone itself your
hair color will come back
your skin will get better
okay
and then i also want you to take our
collagen peptides get the large
canisters and take a scoop of that in
your breakfast drink and scoop it in
your dinner drink don't forget vitamin
d3 take three of those twice today
that's um two bottles a month of our
vitamin d3
and then if you do exercise i want you
to use our rebound or his first drink
with a hundred nutrients in it you don't
not want to just drink you know red bull
and that kind of stuff which just has
caffeine and sugar in it
okay our rebound has a hundred nutrients
and we actually built that for theo
ratliff who lost his contracts the
atlanta hawks he's only 24 years old had
every kind of joint problem you can
think of and fractures in his shooting
arm wrist so he took his contract away
from the atlanta hawks
in 90 days with our healthy bone and
joint pack and our rebound which we made
for him
um he got his position back he played
for 11 more years made over 100 million
dollars taking our supplements do you
think our supplements do a good job
i would say so
yeah okay well there you go let us hear
from you every couple of weeks because
you're going to have a great story okay
sir
well i appreciate that very much dr walk
i always uh love to listen to you on
coast to coast and uh
very uh thank you for my call so that
you know some of these uh supplements
that you recommended for me that would
help me with the uh radiation therapy
absolutely absolutely i'm gonna start
taking them now
okay all right well uh
okay well i'll call it uh i'll uh order
those uh
from whatever your representatives okay
very good
all right thank you thank you sir have a
good day bye
all right thank you and we just want to
remind everybody that if you were
referred to this program by somebody
specific make sure you get back with
them
they took the time to share this program
with you get back with them they
probably have their own special way of
ordering and you're gonna wanna thank
them for sharing this program with you
by ordering through them they will also
be able to help you in this health
journey and keep track of what's going
on and we have many of them that are
certified holistic health coaches so
they have some extra training going into
the four areas of health how they're all
affected by nutrient deficiencies and
how we can use our quality
supplementation to be able to
address those deficiencies
now dr wallach mark has a question here
um he wants to
or he states that there's not much
potassium
in a brain in heart pack do we get
enough potassium from our food
you can but you got to you know
eat a lot of plant life to do it
okay so i like to use our rebound or
sports drink which has a lot of
potassium in it
all right thank you so much and donald
wants to know is there anything he can
do for cataract cataracts for his dogs
for his dog um
they've also been diagnosed with
cushing's
it's an adrenal thing
i'm sorry
it's an adrenal gland thing okay and
diabetes
okay i'm gonna pop with cushing's
diabetes and cataracts dr wallach what
can we do
okay well he must be feeding oatmeal for
the to this dog for breakfast every day
okay
we're talking about his pets right dogs
yes
okay
so
um we need to give one scoop of our
arthrodex for 20 pounds of body weight
to the dog
then uh per 20 pounds of body weight he
needs one
sweeties for
for the diabetes
okay one sweeties
and then
also
for the adrenal problems
uh i want him to poach an egg and
scramble that
either soft scramble it not fried not
hard-boiled but soft scramble or poached
egg and put that into
the dog's food it wouldn't hurt also
to
get a hold of the
if it's a male dog he'd get a hold of
our sarah test and give one of those
tablets of zero tests to that dog for 50
pounds of body weight if it's a female a
zero femme
one of those for 50 pounds of body
weight
and that way
this is going to help from a hormone
standpoint also
all right thank you so much for that dr
wallach let's go to our next hand that
is up and monica
monica go ahead and unmute yourself
thank you live with
thank you so much a pleasure to be here
thank you and shout out to my dear
sister tanya dates for inviting me uh on
this program
i'm 165 pounds 56 years young
and five feet four
i have been diagnosed with hypertension
um i have terrible hot flashes and no
cartilage in my knees and i'd like to
lose 20 pounds
please help
okay all right let's see how tall are
you again
five four
five four okay yeah five four i'd like
to see it weigh uh 130 kind of thing say
maybe 35 pounds a little heavy okay so
to lose the weight we have a meal
replacer called a keto shake it says
shake we used to have bars but the
company that made the bars went out of
business because of the covert thing
okay and so um we do have the shake and
you need to get two bottles of the shake
per month our keto shake and it's a meal
replacer it's not to add to a meal but
it's a meal replacer so you're going to
have one of our keto shake
for a meal it doesn't have to be the
same meal every day and also you can
have one or two of our rebound sports
drinks at that same meal okay then 165
pounds i want you to start out with two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
that's going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes
bone itself including your knees and so
forth
and then um i want you to
also take the msm uh take us
two miles a month for the msm's and take
three at breakfast three at lunch at
dinner time and they will support and
promote mains repair of cart legion
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
upon itself
and then
um you also need the collagen peptides
get the large canister put a scoop of
that breakfast drink and scoop without
your dinner drink that's also going to
help you with your knee issues and so on
and all your other bones and joints in
your body the hybrid pressure once you
get two bowels a month or ultimate daily
classic tablets take three at breakfast
through dinner time don't cold turkey
off your blood pressure medication but
as your blood pressure begins to drop
you can slowly reduce the medication
based on the numbers
okay
um let's see here
and you said you had also hot flashes is
that correct yes
okay then i want you to get two bottles
a month of our zera femme take three at
breakfast for dinner time don't forget
to have three eggs twice a day it can be
poached or softballed or soft scrambling
butter they cannot be hard boiled they
cannot be fried
and
75 of your brain weight is cholesterol
95 percent of the weight of
estrogen and progesterone is cholesterol
do not take statin drugs to lower
cholesterol okay
but you have to have the eggs to get
enough cholesterol to make your brain
happy as well as make your ovaries happy
to make enough
estrogen progesterone okay
all these things you have are
nutritional deficiencies and they can
all go away very quickly but you have to
stay on the program forever
how long do you need oxygen
all the time as long as you're alive
yeah only need water as long as you're
alive how long do you need the 90 cents
of nutrients as long as you're alive
okay so this is where people make a lot
of mistakes well yeah you know you know
after a couple of months i was doing
good so i you know just stopped
uh save a little bit of money well now
you're you've submitted to all that
surgery because you said it didn't work
well it did work didn't it oh yeah but i
stopped taking it well why'd you do that
well
okay and so
you have to realize that nutritional
minerals do not occur in uniform blanket
around the crust of the earth they
current veins like gold and silver so
you cannot just eat the four food groups
you cannot
eat the seven food group pyramid and
expect to get everything you need okay
yes
so that was false information by the
medical doctors are you surprised not at
all yeah they get they get no training
in nutrition and they pontificate on
nutrition
like you know they're the god of
exactly thank you so much dr wallach
well let's hear from you it's toll free
so do call us and people want to hear
you know what happened to monica i will
thank you god bless you god bless you
dear
all right monica thank you so much for
coming on and asking your question
another monika dr wallach in the
comments com said that she added rebound
to her supplements and she does have
more energy
so yeah
is fabulous
yeah and
you know you don't have to play sports
to use it you know you just have to have
you know let's just say you got a bunch
of kids or your babysitting or you know
for your sister or your grandma and your
babysitting for your kids kids and so
forth and they're just wearing you out
you can get on that rebound as well as
in 90 cents of nutrients you'll be a
different person
yes for sure
now dr wellick i
had an email coming to me from zach and
he
says forgive the sensitive topic but
could you please ask doc
what i can do for hyper sensuality
chronic masturbation i'm avoiding sugar
fruit and carbs as they do intensify the
desire
i have no high blood pressure no
diabetes and no ringing in the ears
i'm five foot eight
150 pounds
and 33 years old
okay number one he needs to get a
girlfriend
okay
okay number two he needs to get rid of
all the bad foods no you'll hear this a
lot no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no gluten no we brought right now
so sugar
no carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go he needs to
um eat like an asian rice and sweet
potatoes and beans and squash
no
wheat butter oats no breakfast champions
no oatmeal none of that kind of stuff no
flour tortillas he cannot go to
spaghetti factory he cannot
even go to
um kentucky fried chicken okay none of
that stuff
okay and then of course he needs msm
he's a collagen peptides he needs
vitamin d3
and um
i
uh
and so
he needs all this stuff to kind of
manage all the various stuff going on
he's a young fellow so he needs to
manage all this stuff going on but he
needs to get a companion okay if he's
gay he needs to get a male companion if
he's
bisexual he needs to get a female
companion okay and
he sounds like he's just by himself all
the time
i do not know the answer to that
question
so
great
all right but nutrition is definitely
going to be very beneficial in this yeah
oh yeah
in any type of situation
that's right it's it's essential it's
essential
yeah absolutely
let's go to the next hand that is up dr
wallach and that is
diana diana go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
hi hello
i'm 59
and i'm 5'2 and weigh 128
and i have um
cml leukemia
and i had read your
book that doctors don't lie
a few years ago
and i just recently
got the supplements for it
and i started taking them three days ago
and i feel like really
intense heat in my body yesterday and
last night
is that normal
well if you're feeling intense heat that
means that all the all the engines are
revving up
okay okay but make sure you're staying
away from the bad stuff you know no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
or gluten wheat broth around those sugar
no carbonated drinks you know the
diamond's got to go eat like an asian
rice and sweet potatoes and squash and
corn
that kind of stuff you can have fish
like this morning i had um
tuna
fillets
they come in a bottle and it's like a
big
cylinder okay of a tuna
and they're sliced into fillets i mean
i put that on my wild rice for breakfast
oh my gosh
and so you know you can eat very well
and take the supplements
and
make sure you're getting plenty of
sleeve 128 pounds with a history of
leukemia i'd be sure you're taking nine
a day of our selenium not from walgreens
but honestly with the five cofactors
and so if you're getting one health
abandoned heart pack
okay i'd get
there's one bottle of selenium in the
healthy branded heart pack but i would
also get two other bottles of same so
you can take three at breakfast street
lunch dinner time they're going to
support your immune system okay
very very important here uh they have
the five cofactors in our selenium
that's why you need our selenium okay
okay
and also wouldn't hurt also
cancers don't like oxygen we do have a
wonderful product called oxybody
okay good 128 pounds you could have a
you could have a half ounce
twice or three times a day so you might
want to get you know two quarts a month
of the oxy body
okay and get your oxygen level up there
and uh also our killer biotic killer
biotic um get two bottles of atoms you
can take three of those twice a day uh
the main
killer killer k-i-l-l-e-r
killer now the the main ingredient in
that is rishi mushrooms if you want to
have some fun
go to siri if you have siri on your
telephone ask siri
um
what
you know what is the the history of
cancer therapy and rishi mushrooms
oh my gosh
it's one of the best natural therapies
for every kind of cancer you can think
of as the reishi mushroom and that
that's the basic ingredient of the
killer biotic okay okay
all right give us a call and let us know
what's going on okay another question is
in your book if dead doctors don't lie
for leukemia you said um tiny doses
of chemo
do you still recommend doing the chemo
well um that's the recommended therapy
by medical doctors and on occasion
they'll have some success the reason why
i say modesto says you know you don't
want a heavy hammer you don't want
something you know the relationship well
we're going to give you the big cannon
here we're going to give you the big one
no you want something that's sort of
minimized
but will still
be measurable in your blood so you can
have some positive effect
you don't want to create
a problem by putting too much
chemo into you because that will cause
inflammation and you can get a heart
attack from the chemo
right okay okay
and where could i get that like the area
i live in i live in pennsylvania and we
should we we we we ship everywhere you
don't buy them from a store we ship
everywhere and if you listen
um
okay rebecca is going to give you
some websites you can go to order these
products
i can get the the chemotherapy very
chemical
no no no no you have to get a
prescription from your doctor
yeah see the doctors in our area kind of
don't work on stuff work with stuff like
this
but i do have your products i do have
like okay i apologize okay i apologize
but we're beyond our time here we do
have to run
all right
yes thank you dr wellick we do have to
go on a break so everybody get get up
and stretch fill that water cup with
some water or plant drive minerals
or
hey
the best beyond tangy tangerine if you
have not tried that yet
um it's a little bit sweet just add more
water it mixes up nicely it is
probably the best
alternative to any type of electrolyte
drink that you want to put into your
body but we will be right back with
askdoclive.com or hashtag live
where you can find all of the products
at
askdoclive.com but if
again you were invited by somebody
specific to this program get back with
them
we also have all of the replays from
from our past programs
on
askdoclive.com and dr wallach's most
popular books there if you are not
working with somebody specific we do
have a contact us option on our website
and using that we'll send an e
email to one of our certified holistic
health coaches including myself and we
will make sure that you get what you
need in regards to
your health and creating a healthier
health journey we will be right back
after
this short break
all right and we are back welcome back
everybody thank you for sticking here
with us on ask doc live
again this program is being sponsored by
askdoclive.com but we want to make sure
that
you get back with the person that shared
this program with you whether you're
here live with us
or watching one of our replays one of
the videos from our web our youtube
channel
make sure you get back with the person
that invited you to this program
if you heard about this program through
our newsletter you can go ahead and do a
reply back to that newsletter
and we will have one of our certified
holistic health coaches respond to your
email
there's so much that you can do
on your own
to change the direction of your health
for the better
or the worse if you decide not to make
those changes but we want to make sure
that you are empowered with information
that is going to help you
achieve
the best
possible outcome
ever and let's increase
the life expectancy of
everyone around the world dr wallach
what do you think go ahead and unmute
yourself
i think we can do it
i i know we can do it dr wallach
so let's go ahead and continue on with
the next hand that is up
and margaret
let's go ahead and get you unmuted go
ahead and unmute yourself please
thank you
thank you um
i appreciate you both so much and your
whole team thank you dr thank you um my
husband is 58 years old he sits six foot
six
185 pounds
uh he has some gray hair and he does
have
digestive challenges and we're
healing this all gradually with the
products he's on from youngevity and
he's he's making progress
he's developed
two lumps on the palm of his right hand
that are very sore
about a month ago
and we thought it was just an injury
that would go away but it hasn't gone
away yet and it still hurts quite a bit
okay well i would go to
a chiropractor or somebody like that a
non-invasive person they have access to
x-rays or
scans if they need to
but it could be
um
a joint it could be i mean is it on a
joint where he's got lumps or is it in
the palm of his hand the back of his
hand it's in the fatty part or the yeah
looser that's right
okay well that's where there's a joint
there okay
and so you need i'd go to a chiropractor
somebody like that or okay
and you know when you call them make
sure you you have the ability to do a
scan to see you know if there's an
injury in there or whatever and that's
what you're looking for okay you don't
want to go to an orthopedic surgery well
we got to do a transplant we got to cut
your arm off and you know and so you
don't want to go that well
okay in the meantime
um does he have any other issues any
hybrid pressure diabetes
uh no not those he had high blood
pressure before but he's he's
um relieved himself of that using you
know tangy tangerine and osteofx and so
blood pressure went away
yeah yeah high blood pressure yeah
that's what that's what we do okay
and isn't that amazing
yeah i love it i love it how long did he
have a high blood pressure problems
uh
probably the last 10 years of his
military service and into a couple years
into his retirement yeah well thank you
for his service what what branch of the
service was he in
navy
okay well thank you so much yeah i spent
seven years in the army and 20 years in
the air force i retired as a lieutenant
colonel in the air force
so i appreciate your service i
appreciate your husband's service okay
but yeah give us a call and let us know
see thank you for letting us know his
blood pressure went away and i think we
can do with this hand thing but but see
what it is okay for a non-invasive
person
now okay uh his body weight he needs to
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
gluten you've heard me say it a million
times eat like an asian
rice and sweet potatoes and beans and
squash and you can have fish and he can
have red meat but nothing fried nothing
burnt right
185 pounds only have two healthy brain
and hard packs per month and you know
this but for the rest of our listeners
uh 185 pounds two healthy brain heart
factor a month two bottles a month of
the msm three at breakfast freelancer
dinner time that's for the
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between vertebrae because
we've got something going on in your
hands you got it going on in your back
also okay
um
then he needs in addition to msm he
needs a collagen peptides one scoop of
that his breakfast drink in the morning
one scoop of that and his dinner drink
in the afternoon vitamin d three three
of those twice a day
if you live in a sunshine state unless
he's spending a couple hours in a
bathing suit out in the sun every day
most people when they go outside they
watch the kids play without their shirts
in the sun and they sit in the shade
okay so the animals still need to take
vitamin d3 supplements okay
and if he has pain in that spot we have
the cm cream and some trauma oil put
four or five drops of the trum oil from
aromatherapy oil division
and about a teaspoon of the cm cream but
the cm cream it settles at night the
cream goes down to the bottom water
comes up so you gotta
make sure it's homogenous when you take
it and put it on the joint you'll get
about two to three hours of pain relief
okay
and we can rebuild that joint but let's
find out you know from a chiropractor or
somebody who
has the ability to scan it and see if
there's something going on in that joint
okay
thank you for everything we appreciate
you well god bless you we appreciate you
sharing the story
thank you god bless you too
all right thank you margaret and
now dr wellick
yes john has a question in the comments
so he's 66 years old
180 pounds
and would like your suggestions for
prostate cancer
okay
i don't know what the percentage is but
the diagnosis of prostate cancer
unless they diagnose it with a biopsy if
they just guess because it's enlarged
they say it's prostate cancer
we don't know if it's prostate cancer
it's just enlarged but if they do it by
biopsy it's usually about 99 correct
okay
so here we go
um
got to get rid of all the bad stuff no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat broth right so sugar
no carbohydrate drinks either that one's
got to go and these are the things that
got him in trouble from an enlarged
prostate to a cancerous prostate
whatever it might be
and a lot of times they get up two or
three times at night every couple of
hours they'll get up to go urinate and
the doctors will blame it on prostate
and when really it's a back problem
squeezing the nerves to control the
bladder so you know we don't know all
the information we would ask if he were
live on the phone
okay but anyway so none of the bad foods
then at 180 pounds i'm going to have two
healthy brain heart packs per month
two health brand heart packs per month a
full dose thing twice a day i'm going to
have two miles a month at the msm so i
take three with each meal i want him
also to get our vitamin d three three of
those twice a day two bottles a month
our collagen peptides
that's going to help his immune system
the collagen peptides will help his
immune system also but it deals with the
bone marrow or the white blood cells the
antibodies are formed to protect you
against cancer
and so he needs
again the collagen peptides a scoop of
that with his breakfast drink at school
this evening drink i would not give him
any prostate stimulating
uh supplements because we don't know if
it's cancer or not if it's cancer we
don't want to make new cancer cells okay
so let's just start there
and
in the healthy branded heart pack there
are
supplements in there that actually
support your immune system when you have
cancer
also i would give him
three of the killer biotic
tablets at breakfast and three at dinner
time
okay that'll be one bottle a month of
the
killer biotic and the main ingredient is
rishi mushrooms again you can go
and ask siri
show me some
cancer research with rishi mushrooms and
you'll be amazed at all the great stuff
that happens when you take rishi
mushrooms and you have various types of
cancer
okay
all right thank you so much dr wallick
let's go on to mike
mike is on live with us mike
you are on live with dr wallach
very good i've got five topics that i
could quickly move through with your
comments
let's do let's start with this with a
couple of them mike and we'll see how
we've got for time we've got a few hands
up still
okay right leg above the knee inside the
thigh area i've had bleeding under the
skin which was all about uh four or five
months ago i don't get excited because
i'm on your product i just wait and see
and so i was just curious because it
looks like it's not a problem but
the big pattern is there
okay stop
uh how old are you
i am 80 plus months
okay and how much you weigh
194.
okay
how tall are you
six feet
okay
do you have any other issues are those
are some of the other things we're going
to get into
uh above the knees same leg i have what
i think is referred to as a neuropathy
and that a little bit of pain above the
knee a little bit of hot feeling in the
mornings only i'm not bothered when i'm
moving or through the day
okay
well
uh when you get bleeding under the skin
whether it's in your
uh do you go up and down stairs
uh currently no i have another building
that's got stairs but i've got to repair
them so no i'm not running them down
okay all right now sometimes you get
bleeding under the skin that's because
you have a bone marrow problem you're
not making enough platelets to prevent
this bleeding thing and at age 80. uh do
you have any ring in your ears any
tinnitus or
balance problems vertigo anything like
that
i still have a bit of the tinnitus it's
uh not consistent
okay
okay so here's what we need to do get
rid of all the bad stuff no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bar right now no sugar no carbide
or drinks even the diet one's got to go
and then
i would throw in
uh two healthy brain and heart packs per
month two healthy branded hard packs a
month the full dose everything twice a
day i'd get two bottles a month for the
msms you can take three breakfasts
through the lunch treat at a time and
they're gonna support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
including the bone marrow which makes
the platelets
okay
and um
then
i also want you to get
let's see here that's the msm i also
want you to get the collagen peptides
the large canister of our collagen
peptide stick take a scoop of that with
your breakfast drink scoop that with
your dinner drink that also supports the
bone marrow make more platelets and
white blood cells and so forth
and and this neuropathy it's almost
always a back issue uh
squeezing
the sciatic nerves to go down the legs
and into the feet and so forth
and depending on who you go to
you know doctors will want to do leg
surgery
chiropractors want to have you come in
twice a week for adjustments and you
know it's just endless parade of that
sort of
dealing with the symptoms
but neuropathies are caused by
nutritional deficiencies now get rid of
bad food so you can absorb you take the
supplement program i just gave you and
you you can do fine
uh don't forget vitamin d3 take three of
those twice a day there's two bottles a
month
and um
let's see here
okay and so what other question do you
have
uh yes the uh my comment is i've been on
brain and heart pack uh for two years
and all of a sudden
well the last two months i've been
slightly hungry i could almost live off
the product to it for two years not
scratching my head why are you wanting
to eat more food
okay if you want to eat more food that
means you're minerally deficient are you
eating oatmeal for breakfast
oh no i'm following all of your rules i
have your books and okay okay
so some for some reason you may be
getting cross-contaminated in the
laundry if you're living with somebody
else that does eat gluten and you're
washing your clothes in the same washer
and dryer that they wash your clothes
and you sleep with them and sit on the
couch you walk through the rugs food
preparation surfaces you could be
getting cross-contaminated with gluten
and that's why you're having suddenly
now a change in what's going on okay as
far as
hunger but when you when you have pica
which is a craving to eat
um that is a mineral deficiency okay
so you need to kind of look around and
see what's going on in your house
well i've got a gluten-free claimed
bread i've asked the question are they
lying
could be because i i love when people
say well i eat flour free
bread okay did you read the ingredients
no well what does flower free mean
okay that means
no wheat flour well what about oat flour
what about barley flour what about rye
flour okay
but what's in it
what's the bread made from potatoes or
what
oh no he says gluten free that's the
claim i'm just always suspicious because
i follow your room
well then you call their toll-free
number and find out
what's the flower made from
because
oats have gliadin in them and oats are
not gluten-free but they say it's
gluten-free because they because the
gluten and oats is called gliad
they're playing a word game
they claim brown rice
okay well that's good is it 100 brown
rice or is it got other things in there
you know you need that more detail
you're getting you're getting symptoms
okay you got time for
okay
last comment question mike
yeah the last comment for fun so to
speak my favorite doctor with the white
hair with the white coat is now pushing
eggs
oh
goodbye adding in olive oil oh
no that's what i said too yeah no oils
the only time you can eat olive oil is
when you grow an olive tree in your
backyard you pull the olive off the tree
and eat it that's the only time
you can't have it when it comes out of a
bottle which may have been sitting in
the barn for a year and the heat of the
summer and all that kind of stuff is
oxidized and causes
bad stuff it causes that's what causes
plaque in your arteries not cholesterol
well dr wallach runs around my head all
the time when it comes to okay well
thank you keep in touch with us call us
every couple weeks and give us a status
report okay when you find out more about
what's in that bread uh give us a call
well i'm gonna grind my own brown rice
okay just make sure it's not organic
wheat mike
oh well i guarantee you know i've been
listening to dr wallach and taking the
product for two years so i'm
very well like programmed
okay
fantastic
all right well dr wallach let's go to
the next um question that was emailed in
to me or texted into me and patricia is
55 years old
she's five foot five inches
oh no
yeah
189 pounds
she does take a blood pressure
medication
she's been experiencing tinnitus in her
left ear
the back of her left leg started hurting
last week and has the past couple of
days and her ankle is swollen a little
bit
and she's been experiencing some
palpitations
and
the skin on her leg is shiny from the
oh that's just from the pace that she's
been given so
dr wallach what
what can we recommend for patricia
okay
well patricia needs to get off all the
bad food eat like an asian no fried
foods no processed meats no oils or
glutens no we found rhinos no sugar no
carbonate drinks either that one's got
to go
and then 189 pounds i wanted to have two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
and full goals everything twice a day i
wanted to have
um two bottles a month of our hch
or excuse me let me back up
msm i want to have
two bottles a month for msm msm three at
breakfast three at dinner time and three
at lunch time okay three three times a
day that's two bottles a month for msm
okay
that's going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between ray bone breaks including
the skull
when you have tinnitus either on one
side or both sides doesn't matter
that causes is caused by
a squeezing of the auditory branch of
the astral nerve that's very common with
the osteoporosis of the skull she needs
to get a hold of that book it's all in
her head
and then she needs the
collagen peptides i wanted to have
a scoop of that with a morning drink and
a scoop of that with her evening drink
that's gonna also help her bone marrow
and her bone
um
itself and her skull and every place
else in her body
i want her to also take
the
ultimate daily classic tablets uh she's
on high blood pressure medication do not
cold turkey off of that but as the blood
pressure begins to come down uh because
she's taking the ultimate daily classic
catalyst three twice a day that's two
bottles a month she can
slowly reduce the medication and dosage
based on the numbers
and then
on their skin she can have two bowels a
month of our hair skin and nails take
three of those twice a day
and
that'll deal with the skin everywhere
and the gut problems okay
which usually goes along with all this
um she needs to
make sure that she's gluten free okay
and also she has any belching burping or
bloating any of that kind of stuff i
want her to
take the
ultimate enzymes
we call the gallbladder in a bottle and
she can take
her body weight she could take the two
or three
um
fiber 10 minutes for each meal and
that's going to help her absorb all the
nutrients necessary to get out of her
intestines up into her body that her
liver should be working on but also
um
it's going to make her liver happy okay
so we got to make her liver happy her
kidneys happy
and um her blood pressure happy her
skull happy
and
she needs to lose that weight at 5'5 i'd
have her take one meal a day a meal
replacer is called keto shake the keto
bars are no longer available because the
company went out of business it makes
the bars because of the covet thing
and so we have a shake that's a keto
shake
and so you can also have with that meal
it's a meal replacer it's not the edge
of the meal
one or two
doses of our
um
rebounders fourth drink it has a hundred
nutrients in it and that'll help
um
cut the cravings because when you have
cravings that means you're merely
deficient it's called pica p-i-c-a
okay but i think we can help her with
all her issues
all right thank you so much dr wallach
let's go ahead and move on to the next
hand that is up and it is a cell phone
moto g
i just sent you a request to unmute
go ahead and unmute yourself if you can
come on camera that'd be fabulous but
you are online with dr wallach
good um good morning can you hear me yes
sir yes sir um thank you for taking my
call and allowing me to join the meeting
i've been very helpful
um doctor i've been diagnosed with
psoriasis of the ears
i have um
an abundance my ears make too much skin
and um
it's dry it's itchy it's flaky the
doctor i think he put me on some kind of
pregnancy on drops but they're not doing
anything can you recommend anything for
me doctor okay well how old am i
i'm 64 5'9 165
32 inch waist 44
jacket i'm taking no medication
okay so you don't have any high blood
pressure diabetes arthritis anything
like that
no sir
okay
have any rain in the ears
no sir
okay any balance problems any vertigo or
balance issues no sir
okay do you have any noisy joints any
clicking in your knees or hips or
anything like that
no sir do you have any receding gums or
loose teeth or bleeding gums
no sir okay good all right
so let's get rid of all the bad foods
okay none of the fried foods processed
meats oils glutens wheat broth nose
sugar
even the
carbonated drinks even the diet bones
got to go
and then i'd have to take two healthy
brain and heart packs per month that's
our biggest hammer it would take um
two of those a month to take a full dose
of your breakfast full we'll show you
dinner time and then i want you to take
the msm take two bottles a month of the
msm saying take three with breakfast
three with lunch we have dinner time
that's gonna support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
the bone itself
and also the skin and and so on
which is kind of like tendons your skin
is almost like a tendon
okay and then um you need also the
collagen peptides get the large canister
collagen peptides and put a scoop of
that with your morning drink and scoop
without your evening drink don't forget
vitamin d three three of those twice
today you can have our
um rebound sports drink
okay we have the cans back into the
sports drink so i'm kind of excited
about that
and then we have hair skin and nails
you get two bowels a month of the hair
skin and nails take three of those at
breakfast three dinner time
and
this dry skin in your ears
will go away okay psoriasis is a very
simple nutritional deficiency oftentimes
secondary to gluten issues irritable
bowel syndrome celiac disease
constipation
diverticulitis crohn's disease all those
kind of things they're not autoimmune
they're not genetic they're just simple
gluten get rid of all the gluten take
your supplements
and your complaints
will disappear okay
um
i've i've gotten rid of most of the
gluten doctor and i've gone to i've gone
to the store i've looked at gluten-free
bread
and
i read i read the gluten-free to make it
gluten-free it's it's over processed
it's stripped of its nutrition it's
stripped of its
fiber
and um
it's it's it's it's a very soft doughy
bread with no no texture okay okay
nothing too much it'll stop well that
will stop
all the bad stuff is in the gluten okay
and so this is why i
eat wild rice for breakfast in the
morning instead of
waffles and pancakes
and buns and biscuits and
all that kind of stuff
cereal
i don't eat any of that stuff oatmeal i
don't eat any of that okay
okay you just have to you just have to
give them okay you have to give up bread
i i eat quinoa for breakfast
okay
you can buy organic quinoa at costco at
a good price
mm-hmm
okay
those are gluten-free because you know
what do they add to it
nothing so you recommend give up bread
completely yes
i haven't eaten bread in 20 years
but you said wild rice he said um squash
i heard you say squash doctor i heard
you say sweet potatoes
with butter not margin but butter right
okay and then um
it's an amazing thing you can have irish
potatoes you have the white potatoes
also
um you can have
regular rice but i like the wild rice
yeah
it's one of those things where you know
i don't miss pancakes and things like
that i just don't miss them
because
i i i have a very good breakfast i have
my three
um soft scrambled eggs with butter or
soft boiled with butter
okay um and that's where i get my
cholesterol for my brain and my
testosterone
and so i'm happy everywhere okay
doctor have you ever i can't eat eggs
every day because it constipates me have
you heard of that
nope
but if they constipate you
um you need more
rice
okay
a quick i heard i heard that psoriasis
in the ears could be a result of a lack
of essential fatty acids would you call
that
well that's in the healthy brain heart
pack that's why i suggested that
the healthy brain and heart pack has 215
ingredients in it
okay i'm writing this down thank you
it has 215 ingredients a core of which
is still the 90 essential nutrients but
it also has
um you'll be i i take three of the efas
and the soft shell capsules twice a day
that's part of the healthy brain and
heart pack and three of the fa pluses we
were out of efa pluses for a little
while but they're back in now
and uh
i bought 40 bottles so i get down to the
last 10 balls i'm gonna order some more
so
i take um
six of the efas a day and six of the fa
pluses a day
and i'm 83 years old my skin looks like
i'm 18 years old
wow you look great you look great online
yeah not bad for 83.
so wild rice for breakfast
yep
rice is 90 carbohydrates what do you do
for protein
eggs
um also i have the um tuna
this morning i had uh two big tuna
fillets
okay
but you mentioned that bumblebee or
something like that
i forget the brand you mentioned the
brand it didn't sound like it was wild
caught
yeah these are these are well caught you
know well caught um
um
tuna
you do have to read the labels so
lots of different brands have different
different options yeah yeah you don't
want yeah you don't want them in olive
oil or oils of any kind or anything like
that these are
packed in water i get the ones that are
packed in water
okay so no olive oil the ones and waters
taste like cardboard but um so you say
don't eat the ones in olive oil that's
correct
if you want to get cancer just keep
eating heated oils
um do you add any what do you add to the
it's very dry the chili what do you add
to it to soften it up butter butter
butter butter butter butter butter you
know
what's the first what's the first food
that a baby whale eats what's the first
food that baby elephant eats what's the
first food the baby wombat eats what's
the first food that a human baby eats
mother's
okay milk is the best food
on earth
and all these hippies run around saying
oh you got to be dairy free well they're
the ones that die
overdoses
of these drugs
all right
they'd rather dive in overdose of drugs
and drink milk that's how stupid they
are
oh i'm not sure i think you're on the
west coast but are you able to purchase
non-homogenized milk
you can get any kind of milk you want
anytime from a health food store
but
the milk that isn't
heated to a high temperature and then
cooled and that high temperature kills
all the enzymes get raw milk
right are you able to buy one
everywhere where do you live
i live in florida south florida sunny
south florida
well i guarantee you get raw milk in
florida
okay
great
thank you
you bet
thank you thank you so much for taking
yeah we got to save as many americans as
we can
yes we do who knows russia may be coming
well one one thing about you know when
we're making food choices is sometimes
we do have to search
it's not going to be as convenient as
the boxed processed foods are at the
grocery store but if you look around you
will find
whatever it is that you have the
intention yeah yeah
good point you can you can find it you
know call them call a health food store
and say do you have a range fed beef
a range fed lamb a range fan goat no
okay bye and ask the next one ask the
next one
yeah we have some range fed lamb we have
some range fed chickens okay that's
where you want to go shopping
you know
and let's dr wallace let's not forget
the small brick and mortar
shops that are not big retail box shops
there you go there's there's still local
butchers
everywhere you just have to you just
have to look for them
and tell them what you want that's right
tell them what you want and if and ask
them for recommendations if they don't
carry it
that's another option too
now we have a question here from wayne
in the comments he says
my spouse has gallstones
she started the program for it but he
wants to know can she eat boiled eggs
with soft yolks
i i miss the first part of that question
so
she he wants to meet who's she
who is she's his wife so wayne's wife
who has gall stones
so gallstones okay that's what i was
missing gulstan okay yeah so she started
on the program but he wants to know
specifically can she eat boiled eggs
with soft yolks
she can eat eggs with soft yolks of
course
and of course it wouldn't hurt for her
also to have her gallbladder in a bottle
in case she had a history of gallstones
that's our ultimate enzymes gallbladder
bottle it actually has bile in it which
we've collected from gallbladders from
cattle
okay
and
it replaces the gallbladder and people
get their gallbladder removed
just remember your gallbladder is there
for a purpose to get the bile in your
intestines to combine with nutrients and
then absorb the nutrients combined with
with a bile
to get into your body so if you get rid
of your gallbladder
you're missing a lot of nutrition
because you cannot absorb
the
nutrients necessary that the gallbladder
is designed for to get into your body
so that's why we came up with a
gallbladder in a bottle the ultimate
enzymes
it replaces the gallbladder i appreciate
dr wallach very much not having
gallstones and anymore and i never had
to have any type of procedures to have
them removed and i still notice
that's why you have that beautiful smile
because you have a gallbladder
yes
have almost all my parts still
well monaco said that you had mentioned
two potatoes and she couldn't remember
exactly which potatoes what are your
favorite potatoes
my favorite potatoes for sweet potatoes
with butter and our pink himalayan salt
but if i can't find the sweet potatoes
which it's
impossible not to be able to find them
every store has them but if you wanted
something different we have the irish
potatoes irisa irish you know yesterday
was
saying patrick's day i believe or maybe
it was tuesday whatever it was yesterday
yeah yesterday saint patrick's day
and we have a lot of irish people in
young giving in ireland as well as in
the uk as well as here
as well as in
australia and new zealand
and so um
you know we can't keep track of that
right we well and dr
well like nutrition is not for any
specific
demographic any specific culture we all
were created the same
and need nutrition that's correct
no matter what color your eyes are you
still need
the 90 essential nutrients that's right
that's right
well let's go to the next hand up dr
wallach and deborah deborah go ahead and
unmute yourself
hi can you hear me yes ma'am yes awesome
hi doc um i need a clarification um
on one of my clients that had an um
built a hernia near the umbilical area
and i just needed to re-verify what's
the best to take for that
okay
now all hernias will need the same thing
but for the umbilical area you have to
add two things
number one you get those hernia belts
you can get them from a health food
store a pharmacy without prescription
it's a belt that has a pad on it right
and the pad holds the guts in to where
they belong in your belly cavity okay
you have to wear that belt all day
with the pad on top of the belly button
then they also need to put a 4x4 under
the feet of the bed
at night when they go to sleep
so the feet are four inches above the
head
why is that because gravity will help
keep the intestines down in the belly
cavity
okay
and that that was under the foot of the
bed right under the foot of the bed
okay if you put it under the head of the
bed how's that going to get this going
the wrong direction right
okay
and now the one other question um
for the uh
uh
building dealing with the tetnitis and
the the squeezing of the
tinnitus tinnitus like the mineral pin
tinnitus right sorry yes
um
the glucogen or is it the
msn and collagen peptide the best
you need all three
because they come at this from three
different directions
okay
thank you okay thank you deborah
all right thank you deborah
you're welcome yeah yeah you're gonna be
going to a hospital for a certain major
surgery right now with all those
collagen peptides and
not collagen peptides but but
virus covet virus oh my gosh
you do not want to go to a hospital
right now
okay because everything's spiking again
the numbers are going up because it's a
new variant
it's called the um
uh let's see
it is the
uh
what is it the
covid
oh excuse me the delta delta delta chrom
there you go the delta crop is a new
variant and it's spiking and spiking
like crazy
there are so many different variants
dr wellick i love the fact that
you know through nutrition
we can't prevent it completely
but we can definitely give our body the
building blocks it needs to be able to
fight off whatever's thrown at it yeah
the the whole idea of taking the 90
essential nutrients the same way for the
bad foods
uh is to give your immune system what it
needs to build white blood cells and
antibodies to defend you
vaccines
value is to alert your
immune system to the bad guys dna
vaccines do not kill viruses bacteria
fungus or yeast or cancer cells vaccines
don't kill any of those things vaccines
just alert your own immune system to the
bad guys
okay
this is the purpose for the vaccines
vaccines do not kill viruses bacteria
fungus or easter cancer cells
okay so if you think and that's why
people say well yeah you know i got
vaccinated and then i got covered
well
were you taking the 90 central nutrients
no
did you give up gluten oh no i have to
have my oatmeal for breakfast every
morning well that's why you got that's
why you got covered
because you didn't give your immune
system what it needed to do its job
taking the vaccine is only like 10
of your protection
that's right
well let's go to the next question that
was emailed in dr wallach and tina has a
question
so she has had ringing in her left ear
for about 14 years after she was
standing too close to someone who shot a
shotgun
my ears i i've heard this story before
i've heard this before
afterwards and hasn't stopped since
she says i am on a healthy brain and
heart pact and doing
msm vitamin d and zinc is there anything
else i should be taking
or will this always have the ringing in
my left ear
i'm 66 years old
180 pounds and 5 foot 10. thank you for
all you do
okay
that's tina correct
correct
okay
um
well
she needs the
um
healthy brain heart two helibrant hard
packs she needs two bottles a month of
the msm so you can take three with each
meal she needs a big canister of the
collagen peptides so you can take a
scoop of that with a morning drink scoop
without their evening drink she needs
vitamin d3 okay now she also needs some
anti-inflammatory stuff
okay i'd have her take the uh fucoid z
she could take three of those twice a
day if she prefers a liquid that'll be
two miles a month if she prefers the
liquid the z radical she could take an
ounce to that twice a day it's the same
thing just one the liquid one's a
capsule and the liquid tastes pretty
good little kids like it okay it's
called z radical and i almost tried it
every two quarts a month of the liquid
if you choose a liquid it's
anti-inflammatory now the shotgun went
off did it separate some bones in her
skull to separate the little
um
three little bones in the inner ear were
they separated
by that impact or that gunshot
noise okay um so
the fact that she
has only had slight benefit over these
years
tells me that there's something more in
there than just osteoporosis of the
skull
okay she maybe had separation of those
bones and so that's why she's got
ringing in the ears constantly okay and
so
i would not recommend an x-ray
but
um she can try other things she can put
um
let's see here one of these little
q-tips put a big wad of our cm cream
on it and put it down in that ear and
see if that doesn't reduce the tinnitus
a little bit for a little bit of time
and again if it doesn't
if it does not reduce a little bit of
that tinnitus at all
again the odds are there's been a
separation of some of the inner you know
your ear bones because there's like
three little bones that have to have
contact with each other and they may
have been pulled apart by that impact of
that noise from the shotgun
but try that cm cream down in that ear
all right thank you so much dr wellick
next we have an email from nelly
nelly is 82 years old
says i have severe osteoporosis
had
several fractures
foot ribs twice pelvic fracture
has
incontinence
difficulties to fall asleep waking up
every hour when i do fall asleep what
would be your advice
okay i don't have to be wait
okay we can go by a hundred pounds
okay but who is the fact that she's
getting up hourly during the night to go
to the bathroom and urinate kind of
thing uh that tells me her
back is squeezing the nerves to control
the bladder that goes along with the
osteoporosis stuff okay
so that um
we're going to say per 100 pounds of
body weight i wanted to take one healthy
brain heart pack per month
she needs one bottle a month of the msm
so you can take three of those twice a
day per hundred pounds of body weight
then she needs the collagen peptides i
wanted her for a hundred pounds of body
weight she can take a half a scoop
of the collagen peptides in her morning
drink and a half a scoop in her evening
drink okay
uh she also uh should have
some anti-inflammatory stuff
uh she can take the fucoid z take three
of those twice a day that's two bottles
a month the capsules are if she prefers
the liquid
per 100 pounds of body weight i wanted
to have one part of the c radical she
could take a half ounce twice a day
and let's see what gives here okay but
osteoporosis even at 82 is easy to get
rid of that's a very simple nutritional
deficiency it's not genetic it's not age
and she has white gray or silver hair
which she probably does
the hair color will come back
and that's because hair color loss when
you get white grain silver hair is not
due to aging it's due to a nutritional
deficiency which is very scary because
the same nutritional deficiency will
cause ruptured aneurysms of the aorta
and ruptured aneurysms of the arteries
in the brain and can cause instant death
and so we really need to have her jump
on this fast
yes and dr wallach we had a comment and
the questions from betsy betsy wants to
know can a pinched nerve due to a
twisted hip cause incontinence
yes
because the nerves that control the
bladder in the lower back and when you
twist something
above the hip
guess what it kind of goes upstream also
as well as downstream okay so it can
have an impact on the nerves
that control
the bladder absolutely
and brant has a question i don't have a
whole lot of details but let's go with
per 100 pounds
brent would like to know what you would
recommend to treat crohn's disease
he weighs 400 pounds
no let's go by 500 pounds
500 okay no no no per 100 pounds
so i don't have his weight
okay
and his his name is what brant
brandt rant
okay and you say he has crohn's disease
crohn's disease is what he would like
recommendations for yes
yeah okay
so basically what he needs to do is get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
and processed meats and also gluten no
we buy ryan oats no sugar no carbonated
drinks
and then
um he needs to um
take per 100 pounds of body weight i'd
have him take one healthy brain hard
pack per month
one bottle of the msm per month
one
canister of the of the um
collagen peptides
one bottle a month of the vitamin d3
and uh one bottle a month of the
let's see here fucoid z every prefers a
liquid one quart a month take a half
ounce twice a day
okay for a hundred pounds of body weight
and if he needs to lose weight get the
keto shake
and have one shake meal a day it's a
meal replacer is not to add to a meal
and they can also take the rebounds for
strength
all right thank you so much dr wallach
another product that we have that i have
found to be very
helpful with crohn's disease and other
digestive issues
is our i26 hyper immune powder
so yeah that's our that's our
hyper immune egg
yes
yes so so we give all these
proteins and allergens foreign proteins
and allergens to the chickens and they
put antibodies against them in the egg
and then we dry the egg and put it into
you know
a capsule or tablet
and
it's one of those things where
people who have all these allergies and
the other they really really want to get
on the i-26
in addition as in addition to the 90
they can't just take the i-26 because
they cannot respond properly if they're
not getting the 90 and if they're eating
the bad foods they still have to do all
the basics but the i-26 is for somebody
who really
um
that have a high level of collagen
peptides
okay because that tells you got a lot of
bad stuff going on when you have a high
level of collagen peptides
absolutely absolutely
well
so now i also have
an individual that is wanting to know
about
what she can do
well in general for dry skin so
especially in the winter time she says
her skin gets very dry her heels crack
she's 67 years old
she's
145 pounds
she lives on the east coast she says if
that makes any difference
um and she is taking the 90 essential
nutrients and going with the good foods
bad foods list
okay good that she
wants to add something else to help her
with skin
okay then i would have her add
the collagen peptides okay i get one of
the large canisters as she take a scoop
of that with her morning drink and scoop
without their evening drink but i would
also have her get the hair skin and
nails hair skin and nails and she can
take um three of those twice a day and
that will be two bottles a month of the
hair skin and nails
and um
and don't forget uh at 145 pounds she's
right at that cusp right since she has
that problem it's kind of like a red
warning light she needs to take two
healthy brain heart packs per month
okay and um
that's going to get her
all the nutrients necessary to make the
skin happy
all right thank you so much i know susan
will appreciate that response
and we have judy who has emailed in
[Music]
she said could you tell me how to grow
hair i had covered last october
of 2021 now i'm having after effects of
it for i have been losing my hair in
gobs since
last week in january 2022 i'd appreciate
any information you
can give me
so she gave us no information but she
wants information
she would like information on how she
can stop the goblins i understand her
she didn't give us age or weight or
anything like that no she didn't so much
i know i know her gender because her
name is judy okay
okay
so anyway she's getting rid of all the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no gluten and wheat bread
rhinos so sugar no carbonated drinks
even the diet one's got to go
i want her per 100 pounds of body weight
i wanted to have one healthy brain and
heart pack per month
one bottle of msm
one canister of the
collagen peptides
i want her to have two bottles a month
per hundred pounds of body weight of the
um
of the uh hair skin and nails so you
take three breakfasts for your dinner
time if she weighs 150 160 pounds you
can take um
you can take three at breakfast street
at lunch for dinner time she can take
nine a day but it'll require two bottles
a month to do that
okay
and
um
that but don't forget the msm and the
collagen peptides because the skin is
three quarters of the thickness is made
out of connective tissue
and so we need to deal with that
and um if she has a circulation problem
does she have a blood pressure a lot of
people when they get high with pressure
they're on medication
medications controlling the highway
pressures so they don't mention it
because they got enough quote under
control unquote but have gotten rid of
it but they're just you know we're able
to drop it down into the normal levels
but still the cause of the
um hypertension is still there so you
know we need a lot more information to
be more specific but that's as good as
we're going to get right now
all right thank you so much dr wallach
so dr welling something that we haven't
mentioned in the last
few weeks
and it's something that is so important
and near and dear to my heart and that
has to do with spreading this
information
getting the information out and dr
wallach you have come up with a program
that
sends us thank you checks
for sharing information i know when i
recommend products
to people whether you know before
youngevity
and even recommending a movie i never
got to thank you chuck
and with your crusade and putting
together
this
program and the distribution of the
youngevity products
has created
basically it's kept me out of the poor
house and i thank you for that
i've been able to pay my bills plus
okay well thank you for that and of
course there's two two pieces to that
number one you have to appreciate the
doctors have an advantage you know they
don't get it right all the time they
have an advantage because insurance pays
for everything their mistakes as well as
your problems okay
and then um
so
what i tell people is look if you're in
your retirement age you want to
um commit your
social security check to your supplement
program or at least half of it says
social security
okay to your
supplement program and that way you're
always going to have your supplements
because you get your social security
check every month when you're retired
now if you're not retired yet you got to
say okay i'm going to
devote
200 bucks a month to my supplement
program i'm going to vote 500 bucks a
month to my supplement program for me
and my spouse or whatever and
everybody's got to agree to it and you
just got to
maybe you want to get a separate account
for that you know especially you're
going to do it as a business you want to
get a separate account for it not mix it
with your personal account and
in that way you'll always have your
money for your
supplements you also want to be talking
to your insurance company say hey have
you guys ever thought about you know
paying for
dealing with problems that are
nutritional deficiencies do you ever pay
uh for the nutrients to fix a
nutritional deficiency
uh uh uh uh no okay
so let's just talk about that okay and
let's see we can't get an insurance
company everybody starts asking about it
maybe we'll get one to step out in front
and say yeah let's do it
okay
and um
so along that line dr wallach so there
are com there are health insurance
companies that have health savings plans
and if the doctor recommends
supplementation
then yes you can use
health the health
savings account to purchase your young
japanese products
okay well is there any people that have
done that okay now if those are
available then i urge everybody to do
that
okay because
you can add 25 to 50 healthy years your
life if you start taking these
supplements before you get sick you put
oil in your car and you put gasoline in
your car
before the engine burns up
you don't put all your car after the
engine burns up
okay and so you have to think oh i'm
going to treat myself as good as i do my
car i don't just wash the car
i take my shower every day okay it's
kind of like washing your car every day
but no put no oil in it
okay how stupid is that you wouldn't do
that to your car why do you do that to
yourself
i never thought of it that way okay well
that's the way it goes well my doctor
said i could get everything i need just
by eating the four food groups and seven
food group pyramid well your doctor
needs to go to jail and his license
taken away
okay
because it's impossible
they knew that in 1916 when the u.s
senate document 264 came out and said
there's no longer any nutrition in our
crops because the fields are all
deficient in minerals
as u.s senate document 264 in 1916 it
came out
yeah so people if you want to depend on
the government for information there's
your information right there
the food does not have the
minerals in it
yeah they knew that in 1916.
that's all because of electricity we
went from wood stoves and fireplaces we
had wood ashes to put in the gardens
minerals
we went to electricity no more wood
ashes no more health
that's right
but one thing that i brought this up
before or the reason why i brought this
up dr wallach is
i know that watching this program on
this program with us
and on my team and i know nasima has an
amazing team jaunty's got an amazing
team there's many people on
that that join us every week
that share this information with their
teams and among those people we have not
just house moms
or moms that work from home not just
retirees we have massage therapists
doctors retired and current
um
nurses
nurses pharmacists pharmacists we have
you know manufacturer workers we have
mechanics
you know the list goes on we have
insurance agents
that are joining us in this business
because they're coming across people
every single day dr wallach that are
hurting and they have information
through our program and through other
programs that you have done
that have empowered them to be able to
reach out and have that confidence
so
if you're watching this program and you
have
you are just creating that list of
people that would benefit from
getting this information
reach out to the person that shared this
program with you and say hey share with
me some more about the this
business opportunity because i have
people that i want to help also
if you're looking for something that has
great purpose especially now in a world
where everybody's health is declining
this is an amazing opportunity to add
purpose to your life
and dr wolik it all started with you and
we just want to thank you so much
for being in our lives well thank you
thank you thank you so much rebecca we
are family
and we can be family for the next 25 to
50 years if everybody keeps doing the
right thing
well i'm going to be family for the next
70 years um
so and i know jaunty he's going to be
there with me and nasima she's going to
be there with me so we're going to keep
carrying on dr wallick and we invite all
of our listeners all everybody that's
watching this program to join us
okay
if
if you were not referred by anybody
specific go to askdoclive.com
you can do the contact us there and
somebody will get back with you we do
have for people who have never spoken to
anybody about youngevity they have never
ordered
we do have a call team standing by it
eight five five
nine four nine seven two three four
again thank you for joining us
on ask doc live we appreciate you we
love you
have a very blessed life
and until next time bye for now
bye-bye rebecca bye-bye team thank you
john thank you nasima bye-bye